What's your bedroom like?
My bedroom?
(audience laughs)
Funny enough-
It's just for the fans, Sam.
I'm not asking for myself.
It's for all of,
I'll just throw myself in with you guys, Heughligans.
So what does my bedroom look like?
Yeah, what kind of style of bedroom do you have?
Like what decor do you like?
What's your bedroom look like?
A big bed, Drew.
Big bed, giant posts.
Big posts, and no, I'm so-
Furs.
Furs, candles, firelight, soft music.
It's great.
You should come on over.
And not a pair of underwear in sight.
Never. We burn it.
You know, all of us are hoping
that you're slightly serious.
(audience laughs)
Oh, I'm serious.
(Drew giggles)
Okay, in this season of "Outlander,"
is it true that you asked an intimacy coach for...
And if so, what?
Yes, it is true.
Yeah, yeah
Okay, why?
Because I'm like, wait, you guys have been together
for all these years.
You must have rhythm for days.
Right.
And chemistry.
Rhythm, yeah.
You know, and I actually didn't even mean that
sensually speaking.
No, of course.
I'm trying not to make any sort of innuendos here.
That would be so inappropriate.
No, no, an intimacy advisor, you know,
is kind of a more common practice now in the industry.
When we started, we were totally green.
You know, in your career you've had to do similar stuff.
And as an actor or actress,
you're kind of just thrown in the deep end.
And we were, and we sort of found our way
through it together and we've supported
each other through it.
But actually bringing someone on board
means we're all more supported.
We can find new ways to, I guess, be more intimate
and add more to those scenes.
So I think it's a really welcome addition.
Sounds like people should bring them into relationships.
Let's just all get an intimacy advisor, right?
(audience applauds)
What did you learn?
What can you teach us?
You'll have to watch the show.
(audience moans)
So smart.
You're single.
Wow, why are you asking?
Well, 'cause I heard...
(audience cheering)
For the Heughligans.
Oh, for the Heughligans.
Okay. Okay.
Actually heard that you want to put career ahead
and put romance in the backseat.
Is that still true?
I never said that I don't think, Drew Barrymore,
but I certainly, you know, the job is so all encompassing
and we spend so much time on set and at work so.
Yeah, but I'm open to something.
(audience applauds)
I'm not sure what I'm saying I'm open for, but I'm open.
Well, I know we've been talking about clothing with you.
One of the things that I was curious about
was I heard that you,
something with you in a Batman costume.
Oh yeah.
Well, I don't just wear that to bed.
But no, I played, I did an arena tour years ago now
of Batman live, which is basically like
a sort of cirque show meets Batman.
And I played Batman and Bruce Wayne,
and I still have actually the cowl from our Batman show.
It was pretty cool.
Oh my God, that's you.
Oh God, yeah. There we are.
(audience applauds)
By the way I was in a Batman movie.
You were!
I was!
You were.
Oh my God!
Yes.
Wow.
(audience applauds)
So we have Batman in common.
Wow.
Oh my God. That's fantastic.
(upbeat bright music)